[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Welcome, everybody.
I'm excited today to introduce
Stand.earth and Todd Paglia.
In tech industry,
we have this notion
of the frenemy,
two companies that
compete in one area and
partner in another area.
And Stand.earth has
taken that approach
to environmental activism.
And their approach is to say,
we'll help companies clean up
their act, and act
responsibly with respect
to the environment, show
them how to do that.
But if they don't, then we'll
bring the righteous wrath
of the public down upon them.
And I think this is
a great approach,
and it's proven to
be very successful.
Stand's had great success in
transforming the paper industry
to use forests more
responsibly and in saving
the great rainforest.
We saw some of the
pictures up there
from when I got a chance
to accompany them up
to British Columbia.
And let's let Todd tell you
all about it and about some
of the opportunities where
we can help in this mission
by bringing some
of the technologies
that we have in mapping,
and satellites, and so on.
Todd, welcome to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
TODD PAGLIA: Thanks so
much for being here today.
I want to take you back to the
founding of Stand.earth, which
was in the mid-1990s about
1,000 miles north of here
on the west coast of Canada.
There was a line being
drawn in the sand in a place
called Clayoquot Sound.
The small town of Tofino
is in Clayoquot Sound.
It was the last old
growth rainforest
valley on the west coast
of Vancouver Island,
and people had had enough.
They began organizing to try to
stop the logging of this area.
And it's a rainforest valley
of just incredible beauty.
1,000 year old Western red
cedar trees, Doug firs,
trees so big that 10
people linked arm to arm
could barely wrap their
arms around the trunks
of these trees, and
they're being cut down
to make toilet paper,
newsprint, two-by-fours,
and other products.
So the organizers started
what was a very small effort
in the beginning, and
little by little, gained
momentum, getting people
out to this remote area
to actually put their
bodies on the line
to try to stop the bulldozers
and the logging trucks
from coming in.
And this, for whatever reason--
it was partly the time, partly
so much had been lost already,
people responded.
It struck a nerve.
And hundreds of
people showed up.
And little by little,
thousands of people showed up.
And they began
organizing protests
to try to stop the logging.
The media followed.
It became known as
the War in the Woods.
It went on for months.
And celebrities
started showing up,
and rock stars, and
everybody wanted
to come, and get arrested,
and stand on the line
with the protesters protecting
this old growth river valley.
And it culminated with an
international media storm.
1,000 arrests, the
biggest civil disobedience
in Canadian history,
and it didn't work.
It wasn't enough.
And it was from that--
exceeding all expectations,
every goal they
set as far as turnout,
media, everything they did
went way beyond their
goals, and they still
didn't stop the logging.
MacMillan Bloedel,
the logging company,
just kept moving right along.
And it was from that sort
of moment of desperation
that the founders of
Stand.earth decided
to think about who
was buying this stuff.
So something's driving
what's happening.
So they took a
very basic approach
and went out to the marketplace
with hundreds of letters
to any company they thought
might somehow be connected
to the logging in Clayoquot
Sound and the broader
logging on the coast
of British Columbia,
and companies were concerned.
They didn't realize that
their purchasing dollars were
destroying this rainforest.
And for the first time in
British Columbia-- and logging
was king in British Columbia
and had been for decades--
for the first time, the logging
company was on its heels.
The logging stopped.
They started having to answer
questions to their customers.
They started having to
work to keep contracts.
They started to lose
some contracts, companies
not wanting to be
part of what was
happening in Clayoquot Sound.
And that was the first time
that the companies were really
put on the defensive.
And the trees Clayoquot
Sound, the old growth forest
of Clayoquot Sound
are still standing
to this day because
of that effort
at the tail end of
years of protest
to bring some transparency.
And I think it was this
little glimpse of transparency
of a tree in a forest being cut,
five or six different mills,
way stations, middlemen
to big-branded companies
at the other end.
And it was just a little bit
of a glimpse of transparency
that changed the
entire equation.
So we took that lesson
of Clayoquot Sound
and started thinking, so,
how do we build campaigns
from the front end that, yes,
use communications, organizing,
protests, all the
traditional tools,
but also start to bring some
transparency to the issues
we are taking on?
So from one old growth
rainforest valley,
we decided to try to protect a
hundred old growth rainforest
valleys in an area known at
that time as the Midcoast Timber
Supply area, quite
a catchy name.
The first piece of business for
the groups working on this--
and there were a lot
of other organizations
beyond Stand, including NRDC,
and Greenpeace, and Rainforest
Action Network, and many others.
The first piece of
business was to rename it.
We retained the
Great Bear Rainforest
after the spirit bear, which is
the iconic symbol of the Great
Bear Rainforest.
It's the only place in the
world where 1 out of every 10
black bears is born white.
They're not albinos.
They're not polar bears.
They're actually a white bear
known as the spirit bear,
and revered by the
First Nations who
have lived in this landscape
for thousands of years.
And we started building into
the campaign transparency,
trying to track from this very
remote area wood, paper, pulp,
all the way through
the entire system
to big-branded companies.
So now, we had 100 valleys,
3 companies, and literally
thousands of big-branded
companies buying the product
at the end of the
line, and they had
no idea they were doing that.
So it was a major private
eye investigation effort
to figure out where all this
stuff went to and then to begin
educating the companies.
Our methods got a little
bit better at that point.
We went from just sending
a scattershot letter
to hundreds of companies to
actually tracking the wood,
paper, and pulp using a bunch
of different methods, some
of which meant just
going to mill towns,
and hanging out in the
bar, and figuring out
where the customers were.
So folks at the
bar would say, hey,
we just got a big
order from Home Depot.
We just got a bigger
order from Staples.
We also ended up using--
anybody remember the
LoJack car device?
So we would use the LoJack which
would track your stolen car.
So we would track
our stolen forests
and use that sort of device
to track from especially rail
shipments all the way to
the big-branded companies.
And little by little,
we chipped away
at the transparency
problem we were having.
And a lot of companies, just
like in Clayoquot Sound,
didn't want to be part of
destroying a rainforest.
Over time, it became
millions of dollars
of contracts put online
to tens of millions
to hundreds of
millions of dollars
of contracts put on the line.
And using that power, we
were able to bring industry
to the table.
At the same time, First
Nations on the coast of DC,
for the first time
in a long time,
got organized in a way that
went beyond individual First
Nations.
They became a collective known
as the Coastal First Nations
in British Columbia.
They have not signed treaties.
So they have actual a somewhat
undefined but very powerful
right to title.
And so they became a
political force of their own
while we were driving the
marketplace towards change.
And through a series
of negotiations,
we went from the starting point,
which you can barely see here
on the screen, but almost no
protection in the Great Bear
to a third of it
being protected.
2005, we got to round 50--
no.
2009, we got to 50%.
2015, we put the final
details into place
to get over 80% of the Great
Bear Rainforest protected,
off limits to logging.
And we created fiber flow
processes for the logging
companies to have a
lower impact but be
able to maintain
their businesses.
So it was a real win-win.
And what we found is once First
Nations, environmental groups,
and industry were on the same
page with a very detailed plan,
the government was more than
happy to move forward and move
that into permanent legislation.
So using these methods of
really increasing and building
transparency into
our campaigns, we've
been able to move around 60
million acres of old growth
and endangered forest towards
protection over the last 2
decades.
And we then started
getting pulled increasingly
into climate change.
One of the first issues
that we had to address,
in the middle of this map,
there was a pipeline proposal
by the Enbridge Corporation
to bring a giant tar sands
pipeline.
Right at the point
when we were going over
50% of the Great Bear
protected, heading towards 80,
they thought it would be a great
time to bring a giant pipeline
right into the Great
Bear Rainforest,
bringing hundreds of tankers
into the Great Bear Sea.
This was a fight that
went on for the better
part of a decade.
We were able largely through
leadership of First Nations
groups to beat
that pipeline back,
tremendous organizing
on the ground.
And this movement of people
all around North America
and beyond fighting
oil infrastructure
has had incredible success.
You've all heard about
the Keystone Pipeline,
which has been beaten a
couple of times by now.
The Enbridge pipeline,
we're in the midst
of the fight of our lives with
the Kinder Morgan pipeline
coming into Vancouver on
the port of Vancouver.
We're hopefully going to
be able to turn that back.
But as we as a movement
succeeded on pipelines,
the oil companies
developed a plan B.
The plan B was oil trains.
So if they couldn't get
their pipelines through,
and they were getting delays
and defeats on pipelines,
they thought they might be able
to start moving oil by rail,
and this took
everybody by surprise.
This was something
that heretofore, oil
would occasionally go on rail,
but not very often and not
in any quantity that mattered.
And suddenly, you were
getting about five years ago,
thousands of percent
increase every single year.
And suddenly, there were
more than two dozen oil
by rail terminals, new
terminals being sighted
all across North America.
So what we did is we were
far too small to take on
this challenge ourselves.
We started partnering with
Frontline Communities,
developed a network,
Crude Awakening Network,
which is 275 group strong
at this moment, everything
from a couple of people
working at the kitchen table
to the Sierra Club and Natural
Resources Defense Council.
Banding together, we
were able to begin
to push back on this threat.
And one of the key
components, though,
was getting back to the
issue of transparency.
We created a tool called
The Blast-Zone.org.
And this is a map.
We're somewhere over in here
outside of the blast zone.
As more and more oil by
rail was being shipped,
the trains had a tendency to
explode more and more often.
Usually because a
lot of the rails
are in somewhat isolated areas,
there were not a lot of deaths.
Thank god.
But in some places, there were.
In Lac-Megantic,
Quebec, 47 people
lost their lives in an
oil train explosion.
We had a number of
very close calls
with, for example, an
oil train turning over
in a tunnel in Seattle
during the summer.
It didn't ignite.
But there were so
many close calls
and so many communities
were up in arms
and trying to fight this
that we created this tool.
And it was really kind
of the next iteration
of transparency for us.
This wasn't just
information we were
trying to get for ourselves.
It was information
that we were trying
to get, and then sort
of unleash it, and see
what people did with it.
So you can put in any address
anywhere in North America
and find out how far you were
from the blast zone, which
is the federally-defined area
where you can see from red,
this is basically almost
sort of an incineration
zone to an evacuation zone.
You don't want to be
near any one of those.
And they go right through
many of our cities and towns.
So this was an incredible
mobilizing tool.
We were able to allow groups all
over North America to use it.
And they got the
attention of the mayor
when the mayor's house
was in the blast zone,
the city councilor's house
when their schoolchildren, when
the school was in the blast
zone.
And it also led to a number
of reports that had never
been possible before,
including many of the areas
that we were working
on, like this picture
here, were in very
low-income areas.
And so we were able
to actually use
demographic data, partnering
with environmental justice
groups, to show some of the
new terminals who was at risk.
In many of these
places, it was 80%, 90%
and higher low-income
communities
and communities of color.
This also became a huge rallying
point for these communities
to push their elected leaders to
reject the oil train terminals.
And over the course
of a few years,
we were able, with this network,
to beat over 20 oil train
terminals and really
answer a threat that
was popping up everywhere in
an incredibly effective way.
And a lot of it really came
down to transparency and access
to the information.
The Blast-Zone has been one
of the best tools we've ever
come up with, and
it's the kind of thing
that is really way out
there for groups like us.
It is an outlier,
and it's something
that we actually need to
see a lot more of, I think,
in the future.
Our work on climate change has
gone from oil infrastructure
now more and more into
changing industries.
We have a new campaign actually
launched as of this morning
on the fashion industry.
The fashion industry itself is
the fifth largest contributor
to climate change,
if it were a nation.
So that's about 5 and 1/2% of
total greenhouse gas emissions.
And again, like we've
learned over time,
we're trying to build
more and more transparency
into this system.
And there's a new
fledgling effort
by a couple of our
allies, IPE, which
is a group run by Ma Jun, the
Goldman Environmental Prize
winner, and NRDC is
partnering with this effort
as well, for the first time
to map factories in China
and the brands
associated with them.
So you'll see Puma,
New Balance, Target.
And this is a voluntary effort--
Esprit is also part
of this effort--
it's a voluntary
effort to begin to show
where they're making
the shoes and apparel
that they manufacture.
And this is paired with
real-time pollution monitoring
data.
So any lack of compliance
is going to be known,
and local people on the
ground can access this
and actually go to the factories
and see what's happening.
And the photographic
and other information
you can get when a mill
is out of compliance
will lead directly
to a complaint
to the company that is
the ultimate buyer of what
that factory makes.
And I think this is the very
beginning of what's going
to change the apparel sector.
Our part of this is we
launched our campaign actually
a few hours ago at
Levi's in San Francisco,
the iconic California
jeans company,
and we are encouraging them to
get on the pathway to Paris.
I think part of how they are
going to be part of the broader
campaign is to set a real
goal to reduce their climate
impacts.
This campaign is well timed
because it's very possible.
In fact, they have a
mill that waterless.
They can be running
their mills not on coal,
but on alternative energy.
And this is an
effort that we think
will drive companies to produce
real long-term commitments
and begin mapping
their supply chains.
They're incredibly complex.
And there's no way they
or officials in China
can possibly monitor it and
keep tabs on whether or not
they're in compliance,
but this network
of groups working on climate
issues and local pollution
issues can.
So I think this is really a
whole new world when we're
looking at what's possible
for mapping and giving access
to ordinary citizens, let's
say nothing of local government
officials, about
what's happening
in their homes, their towns, and
cities that might impact them.
And so over time, over
the last two decades,
I think that there
is this trend--
this is a very
imperfect calculation,
the kind only a liberal arts
major would come up with.
But I really think
that our work has
shown over the last
couple of decades
that transparency plus
strategy equals change.
And people like me who are
lawyers, campaign strategists,
media people,
that's most of what
the environmental
movement is about,
and lawyers, and other folks.
And I think we need
to increasingly build
a bridge to folks like
some of the people
in this audience who know
how to manage data, capture
data, and provide
simple access to people
to be able to see
what's happening
in their homes, what's
happening in the world, what's
happening with the companies
that they do business with.
And I think this is
the recipe for change
that we really
have to look at it.
When I look at Clayoquot Sound,
the Great Bear Rainforest, oil
train work,
everything we've done
for two decades as a
pretty small group,
we've been able to
move millions of acres
to protection,
change industries,
and transparency has
been a big part of it.
In the next decade,
you all know we
have a huge challenge
in front of us
with climate change
and many other issues.
I think that to
the extent that we
can get folks that are
campaigners working with folks
that are coders with
common cause to try to map
and provide access to
information for some
of our greatest
challenges, that's
going to be how we provide
the world we want to hand off
to our kids and to
the next generation.
And here's to campaigners
and coders working together.
Thank you so much for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
So that's the
formal presentation.
We were actually hoping to get
into a little bit of dialogue,
because I think you
people who work at Google
and other tech
industries probably know
and have ideas about things that
we would never even think of.
And so if you folks
think about what you do
and some of the things
that we're trying to do,
there's a bunch of
issues that we're
taking on beyond
the apparel sector,
including a new campaign
against the shipping sector.
I'll just give you
one quick story,
working with some
indigenous groups in Alaska
and the Alaskan arctic whose
livelihoods, their culture
depends upon
hunting and fishing.
And the biggest
single threat to them
is cruise ships coming
into their areas.
It would be a huge thing.
If they just knew when
the ships were coming,
and what ship it was, and when
they were arriving, and when
they were leaving.
And there are ways to do that
through different mapping
and commercial vessel
traffic monitoring tools.
But, like, how you take that
information and actually get it
to something that's usable for
somebody in a First Nations
community, an
indigenous community,
so that they can begin to manage
this risk while we put pressure
on Carnival to stay out of there
is just one of the many things
we're like, somebody could
figure this out, but we can't.
So I wanted to just
open it up and see
if you have, first of all,
questions or ideas on how
campaigners and coders
might work together
to tackle some of these things.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
very much for coming
and for your presentation.
And I think that you and I
should talk later longer.
I lead the Google Earth
Outreach team here at Google.
And our mission is
to empower everyone
to use Google's
mapping tools to change
the world in a
positive way, and we
focus on different social
and environmental issues.
And I won't take
up this whole time.
It's not my podium.
But fishing, so you
probably may have
heard of Global Fishing Watch.
So our team did that.
And what a cool idea to
repurpose that same data,
apply different kind of machine
learning and proximity alerts
to be able to give
real time updates
to indigenous communities
in Canada or wherever.
We work very actively
with the First Nations,
and aboriginal groups
in Canada, as well
as New Zealand, and Australia,
and, of course, US, and Brazil,
and many others.
So I see a lot of things
that could be repeated.
And of course, with
Google, you want
to start somewhere and then
repeat it and scale it so
that everybody can have access.
And so there's that.
I love that idea.
So yes, we should talk.
That's a very cool idea.
Second, supply tracking
is something that--
we were at Rio+20.
And Rio+20, I remember being in
this panel with Unilever's CEO,
and Richard Branson,
and a couple of others.
And they were saying,
the Consumer Goods Forum.
And I know that
that's still active,
and I know Consumer
Goods Forum is
doing great things
for sustainable
management of goods.
But I feel like
the tools out there
aren't living up to
the people's needs,
your needs for supply tracking.
We've talked to Patagonia.
They're, like,
superior in their kind
of mapping their supply train
for some of their products.
They're also interested.
So there's a big,
huge desire for it,
but it's super complicated.
And I think even
though Google has data,
we're starting to understand
that for our own products,
how to track our consumer goods.
But we don't have the
history and probably
the breadth of
knowledge that you have.
So I'd love to have a
conversation about that,
how we can map those.
The map you have is fantastic.
But then, how do you map--
how do you track?
How do you tell
that kind of story?
And we're good at
telling stories,
but it's a different
kind of story,
and you can't just throw it
into some story template.
You got to really
understand pathways.
TODD PAGLIA: And
it's not static.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TODD PAGLIA: Each year, there
will be new factories to map.
AUDIENCE: Yep, totally.
Yep.
TODD PAGLIA: It'd have to be
flexible and able to adapt
to changing circumstances
on the ground.
AUDIENCE: That's right, yeah.
And the last question I'll have,
and I'll let somebody else talk
or you can keep
going is I would love
to know-- so I lead the effort
to map air pollution worldwide
and get that data into
everybody's hands.
And one of that is just there's
the lack of measurements,
so we're trying
to help that, too.
And so I would love to know
when you talk about pollution,
have you heard of the
Landsat group Pure Earth?
They were part of
the Landsat report
that just recently reported
that one in five people
die of pollution.
There's lots of different
kinds of pollution,
but one in five people die
of pollution in the world.
TODD PAGLIA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And what's interesting
about that is they're
trying to map it, so might be
an interesting collaboration
there.
But I would love to
talk more about, like,
when you said you
connect those supply
chain factories with pollution,
what kind of pollution?
Where do you get that data?
Because in China,
that's very sparse.
Air is one thing.
I know about air, but I don't
know about the other one.
TODD PAGLIA: Well, so
there are actually--
and this is largely
the work of IPE, which
is a very small group like us.
But they have been
able to access--
there's not a lot being
done with any information.
It's real-time water
pollution information
on a bunch of different
chemical outputs
as well as air pollution.
And because the government
is relatively small
and doesn't enforce, nobody
does anything with that data,
but it's there.
AUDIENCE: And who put that-- did
they put it on the factories,
and the factory voluntarily
put it on their [INAUDIBLE]??
TODD PAGLIA: The actual
government is requiring it.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
TODD PAGLIA: And so what's
happening is basically,
IPE is tapping into that data
and just beginning to map it.
But it's not leading to
any compliance efforts
by the Chinese government.
But when something gets out
of compliance and people
email these companies
directly, it gets fixed.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TODD PAGLIA: So
expanding on that
and having somebody
other than us, and IPE,
and NRDC doing this
would be incredible.
AUDIENCE: That's amazing.
What does IPE stand for again?
TODD PAGLIA: Well, in Chinese,
it makes a lot more sense.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: OK, so I'll
follow up and we can
talk more about ideas together.
TODD PAGLIA: Yeah,
that sounds great.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you very much.
I really enjoyed
your presentation.
I also would like to second I
love the idea of transparency
as a tool to allow people to do
what they want to do and know
is right.
I'm part of the
Geo Organization,
and my teams do the aerial,
and satellite, and street view
geometry and reconstruction
of all over the planet.
And I'm also heading up the
nascent geo augmented reality.
And we are interested
in what kinds
of applications using
augmented reality--
So what this means
is that Google
has this incredible asset of a
very rich, detailed, physical
model of the world.
And we can marry
that with people
being able to create
content, virtual content,
and pin it to the world,
and it's [? ACLED ?]
and shared appropriately.
So as you were talking,
I was thinking, boy,
I could easily imagine
applications of somebody
holding up their device--
or there might be headsets
in the future--
looking at the
dress in the window,
and not just getting information
about the cost, and sizes,
and so forth, but the source of
where the material came from,
what factories, what the
environmental footprint
of that, and maybe even
push a button that says,
tell the manufacturer
that you love this dress
or you'd love it even more if
they were more responsible--
something like that.
So I would be very interested in
talking with you and your team
about what applications could
be developed using this ability
to augment a model of
the physical world that's
visible to anyone
and would give them
more information
about the products,
maybe holding it up to
factories in the city
to tell you what that
factory is doing,
and putting it right
in the hands of people
on their mobile devices.
TODD PAGLIA: Yeah, that's great.
One of the things that's been
incredible over the last, oh,
year or so is that
we've had so many more
people wanting to
be active, wanting
to try to take control
of the choices they make,
what's happening in
their cities and towns.
And we've had, in
some cases, like,
add a zero to a number
of people showing up
for a protest or demonstration.
And so right now, the
appetite for people out there
to actually have information
they can take action on
is higher than it's
ever been in my 20
years of working on this stuff.
So that would be an
incredible tool to have.
AUDIENCE: And that's just one.
This group also--
and you're related
to the Sunroof Group of
identifying good areas
for putting in solar panels.
We could partner with stuff
like that, also again,
with augmented reality,
where you could
have virtual landmarks
to show you appropriate
places for whatever.
This is a fertile area
for attention in some way.
You can do that with
virtual landmarking.
TODD PAGLIA: So I have a
question maybe for you, too,
but maybe for someone else.
So one of the things
that we were thinking
about with the shipping
issue is that these ships
run on a variety
of different fuels.
And we're trying to get
permanent change towards much
more sustainable fuels,
but the switch fuels.
So in addition to being able--
like we had a very small system
that allowed us to track--
it was really funky and put
together by volunteers--
to track ships in
Puget Sound that
were carrying tar sands oil.
And then we would
kind of lose them
at the mouth of the
Strait of Juan de Fuca,
and then they would show up
elsewhere at certain times.
It was very funky,
but some people really
liked it because they
would be out in the islands
and they could see a tanker and
say, that's a tar sands tanker.
So that feels like that's
something that's very possible.
And the thing I
was wondering about
is because of the
fuel switching,
again, what we've seen
over the last 20 years
is government shrinking.
There's no enforcement
of fuel switching.
But is there a way using
satellite data to tell, like,
if you look at the ship--
AUDIENCE: What do you
mean by fuel switching?
A boat goes up next to
it and they're like,
OK, let me give you your fuel,
and then you go off, and--
TODD PAGLIA: So this
ship right here,
it would still be horrendous,
but there would not
be a black plume of
smoke when they're
within certain
distances of the shore.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
TODD PAGLIA: Right?
And then they switch to
a different type of fuel
once they're a dozen
miles offshore.
But nobody knows if they're
actually complying with what
they're--
AUDIENCE: Cheaper [INAUDIBLE].
TODD PAGLIA: Exactly.
They mostly use heavy fuel
oil, which is actually
a solid at room temperature.
It's like the grossest stuff
you could possibly burn.
But is it possible
to in addition
to mapping the ships, could
you figure out how to map
what they're burning?
Because there's a
footprint, a visible
footprint in many cases.
AUDIENCE: Well, as micro
satellites become more common
by some companies on
the planet, for example,
we're going to have
an eye in the--
the society is going to have
an eye in the sky in more
frequent intervals.
And that's good because their
mapping satellites are, like,
one meter or five meters.
Like, you can see every--
at least twice a day--
don't quote me, but if you
can imagine a world where you,
like, twice or
three times a day,
you could see that's a ship.
Wow, look at the plume.
It's a half mile
long and this color.
That's good.
I don't know if we're
quite there yet.
I'm not a super expert,
but when we all talk,
you can connect to the
right people that know more.
AUDIENCE: Hi. thank
you so much for coming.
I actually come from a long line
of sustainability work myself,
and I was at the WTO
conference in 1999,
if you remember, in Seattle.
TODD PAGLIA: I was there.
In tear gas.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah, me too.
[LAUGHTER]
And anyway, so I've been in
the sustainability movement
for a very long time, ranging
from United Nations conferences
to the WTO to a lot of others.
And what has struck
me time and again
is that every time I go
to these conferences,
and then we'd go out--
some of us panelists
or attendees
would go out to dinner,
and we'd go out.
We'd leave the hotel, and
there's the real world.
There are people
walking on the street,
and they're looking at their
iPhones, and they're chatting.
And I'm like, do they
think about these things?
And so over these
years, and also because
of a previous
career in Hollywood,
being kind of on the other
side of things in storytelling,
it kind of dawned on me over
time that what you really need
is storytelling on a very
emotional, very emotive level,
right?
TODD PAGLIA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And that
has to start young.
I mean, I have a
seven-year-old daughter,
and she loves Minecraft, but
she also likes little birdies.
She'll stop dead and just
look at hummingbirds.
And so I think if we can
encourage in our children
this very real connection
to the real world, not just
technology, right?
It kind of has to go
hand-in-hand, I think.
Because if not, then we
really become disconnected,
and I see that.
So what I'm actually
actively doing is in my team,
trying to see how
can we use technology
to tell these
stories, not overtly.
Not saying, hey, did you
know that you should never
go on a cruise ship
because they pollute?
But tell stories through
mythology, through fiction,
through narratives.
I would love to see
"Game of Thrones"
mention something about that.
AUDIENCE: What team are you on?
AUDIENCE: Google Assistant.
AUDIENCE: All right.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And so we reach out there.
And for example, we
have Earth Day content.
And I also suggested,
well, if you
do Christmas holiday
suggestions, why don't you
put in something
about green Christmas?
And so my team liked that.
So even little
tidbits like, hey,
consider the packaging
that you're buying,
because the gift wrapping gets
ripped off, and off it goes.
It's one use.
TODD PAGLIA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So that's what I'm
thinking about constantly
is how can we tell these
kinds of very emotive stories,
and as young as possible?
TODD PAGLIA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I'm not
trying to brainwash,
but it's just how we're
biologically wired.
We're biologically
wired for stories,
for the stories of our elders.
Our elders right now are movies.
TODD PAGLIA: Yeah.
And the environmental
movement needs a lot
of help with the
stories, because we're
getting a little better at it.
But the story that
everything is terrible
and we're all going to
die is really not working.
AUDIENCE: It never did.
TODD PAGLIA: We have
a campaign right now
against Starbucks
because of their cups.
This is just an
example of, like,
to think about how we could
tell this story better.
So their cups are
not recyclable.
Everybody thinks they are.
They're not.
They go here four
billion of them per year.
And this is our
cup wall, which we
have in front of
their headquarters
every once in awhile, which
is 8,181 cups, which is 1
minute of Starbucks cups.
And so if you think
about storytelling,
so you have a forest.
And then the process
to make this cup,
it's in your hand
for 20 minutes,
and it's in the
landfill forever.
AUDIENCE: Are they compostable?
TODD PAGLIA: Nope.
AUDIENCE: Why aren't
they compostable?
TODD PAGLIA: Because
they just haven't
been sufficiently motivated,
but we're getting there.
Yeah, it's a plastic liner.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TODD PAGLIA: Yeah, I know.
Well, the thing is
they're kind of like--
I joke about them being
sort of like Canada.
Like, everybody, because of
health care and the good things
Canada does, they think
they're environmental.
Same thing with Starbucks,
because they are really
good companies as far as--
AUDIENCE: Fair trade.
TODD PAGLIA: Fair trade,
good wages, pay for college,
hire all sorts of
different groups
of post-military refugee.
Like, they're great, but
they're terrible on this issue.
And there's got to be a way
to tell this story that's
empowering and not, like,
oh, another bad thing,
because they're going to change.
It's going to take
us a little while,
but they're going to change.
But it's exactly, I
think, the kind of thing
that we need to tell
in a better way.
So tell me how to
tell that story.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
the interesting talk.
So in the spirit of what
previous questioners have done,
I'll start with
my qualifications.
I was camped at the Black
Hole in the summer of '93.
You'll know what that means.
[LAUGHTER]
But my question is
about transparency,
and I'm wondering what the
obstacles have been to that.
For example, I would think
a forest company wouldn't
want its competitors knowing
who its clients were,
or an apparel
company's competitors
knowing who its suppliers were.
TODD PAGLIA: Transparency
is always impossible.
AUDIENCE: What obstacles
have you run into with that,
and what can we do about it?
TODD PAGLIA: Yeah.
We started tracking or trying
to track extreme oil, so
oil from the tar sands.
And we were told by our
allies, funders, and companies,
you cannot track it.
Like, it was not possible.
Not only do they not
want it to be tracked.
They didn't think it
was possible to track.
But if you think about
it, it's a little bit
like pulp and paper, which they
also said it was impossible.
But it's all connected.
Like, with oil,
it's even easier.
It's a pipe.
Like, it's a pipe from one
place to a refinery, and a pipe
from there to somewhere else,
and then eventually to trucks.
So we started going about
mapping it not the way
you folks map it, but very
sort of, like, notebooks,
and tracking a truck that left
a certain refinery that we knew
had tar sands, following
it to a refueling station,
and then seeing corporate
semis come in and refuel there,
thus linking them
to the tar sands.
And so we did that.
And eventually, we got
all these companies
to agree to get off of using tar
sands oil to fuel their fleets.
They didn't like it
because they don't
want a lot of transparency.
It results in a lack of control.
And the whole idea that
everything is a trade secret
is insane, and that's
what they usually
trot out in one way or another.
But what we've seen
over the last 20 years
is once transparency is
sort of forced upon them,
that they operate just fine.
Everything from pulp paper to
two-by-fours, like, yes, there
are some things that are actual
trade secrets 99% of what they
say are trade secrets are not.
And so we're willing
to carve out that 1%.
Fine.
You can keep that secret.
But the world, I think, is
going in this direction,
and Google is one
of the drivers.
And I think that
companies that are
going to succeed in
the next decade-plus
are going to be able
to deal with it.
And those that can't are
going to suffer, I think,
in the marketplace.
And it's not something
they're going
to like or be comfortable with,
but it's happening anyway.
And every industry that we've
seen that we've worked with
has said it's impossible and
then was able to deal with it.
So I think it's more
myth than anything else.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Well, thank you, Mr. Paglia.
Thank you, everyone, for coming.
TODD PAGLIA: Thank you for
your questions and your ideas.
I really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]